[Applaudissements]
bien sûr que c'est lui et non n'y a pas
de trucage ans non mais quoi qu est ce
qu il a mis sa poitrine témoin que m'a
précédé le soutien gorge
non mais c'est vrai que avait eu là vous
n'avez même pas la poitrine de
l'accident se permettre non mais il
irait beau george a pas de mal à ça
s'abroge baptiste non s'écouler vous qui
connaissait la beauté ouais il est bien
où ils vont bien le tort physicien le
taf reebok tous les bons coups je
connais il fait déjà beaucoup
d'équitation et celui-là ça c'est dur
faire ça tous les muscles
non non pas les faux autrefois de
contorsionniste 3-2 fait pas grand cas
baryton prêts à décoller il est bien là
dessus baptistin et on voit bien là
reste je vais pas les mettre les deux là
comme récemment c'est pas la même c'est
quoi un comprimé le pantalon qui
n'achète rousseau pour la la on passe
pas le même mois de septembre
d'ailleurs la gsm retour en corse ils
arrivent ils sont contents et l'arabie
mballa ça vous tombe sur le coin de la
gueule à ce n'est pas la même c'est pas
le même désir la prochaine photo ah
ouais ça va être chaud il se prend la
tête là il était sur un contrôle de
maths de ziff plus de 720 de change
tu as raison mais si aujourd'hui je veux
dire le monde de la coiffure échangeons
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
bujumbura choix allait bien ça vous fait
rire à mathieu que vous en pensez je
préfère et qui non non non mais en plus
c'est comme il est mannequin aussi j'ai
appris ça n'est pas dans sa voix lasse
et ses deux deux styles différents et
c'est deux styles deux mains car voilà
bayard mal car le de djerba c'est la
photo la plus récente mais c'est faux
c'est baptiste après avoir passé deux
mois chez ma mère savait pas le cerveau
après trop de vous l'êtes également là
il a man les frères ils sont démontés
passé c'est françois hollande est ton
président et maintenant allez on y va
c'est un métier très bon comme ça toi tu
le sais très bien où la sallaz je veux
pas savoir qu'il a fait c'est de la
rousselle adjoint permanent
je vois bien battu attendez on voit là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par ailleurs
il ya moins de gens à la fois le fasse à
un poisson l'aide s'est mis à mal les
abdos quand même les abdos sont vos
après l' île c'est vrai que là des
petites gens à manger tout ce qui tombe
à écouter tout ce qui est en haut et
bien c'est en bas ça part en cacahuète
pour il est mort je sens que vous allez
ralentir le rythme non non je voulais
savoir si mathieu s'épilait pour ne pas
avoir de poêles de masse régisseur du
milli moi j'ai pas de poils n'a pas bah
ouais ouais ouais non mais à ce point
commun et a pas de poil alors celui-là a
well as il faut être très beau gosse
pour la paix créée là c'est quand ils
attendaient le bus à ses soldats il est
comme ça on entend le son mythe
je vais vous oblitéré c'est parti
regarde c'est qui a ouais ouais ouais là
oui il attend le bus pour rentrer à la
maison de retraite mais mes gens me
parlent pas sa phase six celle du qatar
ouais ouais ouais on en a lui même
dernière ah oui ça là c'est la meilleur
série c'est toi c'est tout ça non j'ai
pas le temps de le faire
ouais ouais tu pas eu beaucoup de
travail
[Applaudissements]
sur l'attaquant merlu est plus la même
chose las de ce côté là on a un mec il
est beau gosse tu vas faire un football
américain et là on a bonne tu tires ou
tu pointes
non le cochonnet le mondial de pétanque
aux arts sous une chaleur tropicale
le cochonnet volts si thierry moreau qui
va s'élancer mais tu aimes bien
non mais franchement haïti tignes a
essaimé
il a les pesqueyroux l'intérieur ouais
ouais en fait là son corps qui veut se
barrer il a le salaire c'est son corps
il va dit mais je peux en parler je
prends les booster et merci et c'est le
contraire de kim kardashian
non mais c'est vrai la dalle est en
toile et là là et là c'est tout est
rentré rentrée en lui mais thierry est
mais je vous jure à vous si vous n'êtes
pas mal c'est bien mais j'en fais on
rigole mais il est pas mal joué mais
c'est non
thierry je vous jure je trouve qu'il y
avait un truc quoi là je sais pas encore
bah c'est pas milla [ __ ] c'est pas à
bouteilles d'eau les cherry on a je
crois qu'on allait et n'avait pas fait
une photo vous si vous tombez alors
attendez oui à la voie à trois bien sûr
également away a oui ça qu'ils ont fait
regarder et regarder que les bold à rien
un truc aussi n'ont rien franchement